Hikaru played his most brilliant game of
the grand Swiss defeating the world
number two Fabiano kowana Hikaru BS back
against Fabiano in the candidates in his
vides game then he has beaten him in
Stavanger and now he's beating him again
this is incredible I don't really Rec
call anyone beating Fabian in three very
important games ever in their career but
uh here it's happening within one year
while Fabiano hoped Hikaru would play
for a draw in their game after boxing
out Bob's Queen Hikaru never took his
foot off the gas leading to a brilliant
Bishop sacrifice that gave him a strong
in-game position where Fabby could
barely move from there hikaro exchanged
everything after he won this Pawn he
created two winning pass pawns and
forced Bobby to resign with this win
Hikaru shares the lead and is in a great
position to land himself a candidate
spot with either a tournament win or by
rating and an all started win